Here's what the testLocationTable
method looks like.
First, we grab a reference
to a writable database
because we'll be modifying the database.
Then we create content values for
a row of location data using
the function within test utilities.
Then we insert that content values
object into the location table.
The return value of the insert
statement should be row ID.
If it's negative one, we know
the insertion failed, so we assert that.
Then we query the location table and
pass in null for all the parameters
to get a default query of all tabled
rows and columns, since we want
a precisely verify that our database
only contains our inserted record.
The query will return a cursor.
And we are assert if we cannot
move it to the first row.
Finally, we call validate current record
from the test utility to validate
the query will return
the correct record.
Validate current record
grabs the set of value pairs
from the content values
that we inserted.
It then iterates through them,
using cursor.getColumnIndex
to get the index of each column
in the record set by name.
We need the column index to
get data from the cursor.
Note the projections
are always return in order.
So if we specify a projection,
we can safely use the indexes from our
projection array without having
to look them up like this.
Let's go back to our test.
We checked to make sure the database has
only one record by making sure we moved
to next fails, then we close the cursor
and database, we don't leak resources.
Finally, we return the locationRowId.
Let's run the test and see what happens.
And the test past, [SOUND],
only one more test to write.